ahora que vamos a construir una araña
veamos lo que contiene el kit tenemos la
lámpara adherible que va a ser el cuerpo
de la araña y tenemos algunos conectores
de pymes tenemos nuestro arduino nano
algunos palitos de madera que vamos a
usar tenemos anillos el e y el
controlador del motor mlt dos motores de
5 volts de juguete también tenemos dos
tapas roscas perforadas de tamaño grande
y otras dos tapas roscas con
perforaciones más pequeñas
además tenemos dos baterías o pilas de 9
volts lo siguiente es un cable de mini
usb lo que nos va a permitir conectar a
nuestra computadora nuestro arduino
tenemos cuatro conectores de cabeza de
pin hembra a hembra
también tenemos un cable que vamos a
necesitar para conectar todas las partes
diferentes y conectores para baterías de
9 voltios estos lo necesitamos para
llevar la energía de las baterías a
nuestro controlador del motor también
tenemos una arandela es un sujetador de
arandela y dos luces leds de tres
colores rojo verde y azul
vamos a necesitar dos resistencias
y nos queda una en la caja y también
necesitamos un clip
finalmente necesitaremos cinta aislante
o plástico para envolver que usaremos
para cubrir las conexiones eléctricas
ahora veamos las herramientas que vamos
a necesitar para armar todas estas cosas
hacemos esto a un lado
y vamos a necesitar un pelador de cables
o también pueden usar tijeras o pinzas o
pinzas alicates para quitar el aislante
del cable estas son las pinzas alicate y
les recomiendo que tengan una para este
proyecto también necesitaremos pinzas
regulares que usaremos para sostener y
doblar cosas también tenemos nuestra
pinza nariz de aguja que usaremos para
doblar cables en lazos tenemos un
pequeño destornillador
y también usaremos una pistola de
silicon caliente
también vamos a necesitar soldadura y un
cautín que nos permitirán unir los
diferentes cables de manera permanente